-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Rachel Maddow.
We were talking about empathy,
and I feel like one of
President Biden's best qualities
insofar as what attracted voters
to him
is that he's very conciliatory
in nature,
which I think a lot of peopl
were looking for in this moment.
I believe
I'm an empathetic person.
I don't know if I'm as
conciliatory as President Biden.
Do you think that's
the right tone for this moment
-Well, it's better
than the opposite, you know?
I mean, if we had a presiden
coming in right now
who was bent on vengeance
and hunting down those
who disagreed with him
and making sure they were
run out of civilized life
like some presidents I know,
I think that would be a ba
thing for the country right now.
I mean, Biden --
the thing about Biden
is that everybody
knows who he is.
He's been consistently
that person
and that type of politicia
his entire life.
The country voted for someon
who they knew.
And part of what they know
they're getting from him
is somebody who does want to b
a president for everybody,
who isn't out to set peopl
against each other
and to make it
the haves versus the have-nots
and vengeance on my enemies.
So, I mean, I feel like
every president at the outset,
Democrat, Republican,
conservative, liberal,
and everything, deserves
sort of our best hopes
and our support
at the beginning.
And I think a lot of
my hope for Biden
rests in that radical empathy.
I mean, he is way more
empathetic than I am,
and I feel like I have thing
to learn from him on that front,
and I hope it serves us well
But there is stuff from th
Trump era that needs cleaning up
and I also hope he's going to be
able to do that.
-Look, I'm not saying that COVID
was an easy problem
for any president to deal with
right?
A worldwide pandemic is, you
know, is going to test anyone.
But it did seem like we were
dealing with a lack of a plan,
and now there is
a plan in place.
We don't know
how successful it will be.
But it doesn't seem
that difficult,
the steps that Biden
is asking us all to take.
-Yeah. Like, there's, you know
the very basic A-B-C
public-health approach
to dealing with
a respiratory, transmissible
potentially fatal virus.
Like, it's not like they'v
invented new things to do.
They're just starting to d
the stuff
that we should have done
from the very beginning.
There ought to be a national
plan for tackling COVID.
There ought to be
a national vaccination plan.
Trump never had one of those
There ought to be
a contact-tracing plan
and support for
implementing that.
There ought to be support fo
schools who are having to change
everything about the way they do
in order to contend with this.
I mean, all this basic stuff
that should have been
put in place a year ago,
Biden is now putting in plac
for the first time a year late
because the only thing Trump
ever did was a travel ban.
And, you know, meanwhile,
banning people
from other countries didn't stop
us from becoming the country
with the largest death toll an
the largest epidemic on Earth.
So, I mean, I do not envy
Biden and Harris
the job that
they are inheriting.
But I do think that one benefi
they have is that the guy
who they're replacing
didn't even do the easy stuff.
And so they don't
have to invent
new complicated trickery
in order to come up with wha
U.S. government policy
ought to be.
It's just the basics.
-Obviously a lot of
very serious things happened
during the Trump administration,
things that, as you pointed out,
are going to take years to undo.
With that said, do you hav
a favorite stupid scandal
of the Trump administratio
that only brought you joy
that you're going to miss?
-Oh. Like, go back to
the Trump scandal orphanag
and choose one?
-Yeah.
You can bring one with you
Like, I would love if
a President Biden also, like
used a Sharpie to adjust maps.
I think that was a fun thing
I don't think enough president
have done that,
and I think that should be a
thing presidents do from now on.
-Do you remember --
Well, okay, it's a tie.
First of all, Trump had
the Interior Secretary guy
who had a flag made for himsel
that every time
he was in the Interior Secretary
headquarters,
a staffer would have to run up
to the roof and fly his standard
to alert the peasantry that th
Interior Secretary was there
That was pretty good.
But then there was also
the EPA guy --
I don't even remember
his name --
who built a super secure
"Get Smart" spy telephone boot
in his office so he could have
uber top secret
EPA conversations
with the White House.
That was --
and then he had, like --
he hired himself
a 24/7 security guard,
and things that turned up on
the, like, reimbursement sheet
were things like ballistic pants
for his EPA security team
that, you know,
would keep him safe
when he was going
into the phone booth.
-I feel like every Cabinet
member for the next like
three months is going to
keep reporting back like, "Hey
do you know there's a solid gold
microwave in my office?"
-[ Laughs ]
That's right.
-So that'll at least be
something to look forward to
Have a great day tomorrow.
Very happy you'll be covering it
live throughout the day.